if you've ever wanted to make your own
VR game the new Nintendo lab Oh kits let
you do just that
and Kevin you and I just got a chance to
experience it level is of course
Nintendo's sort of cardboard based
creation system you can make what they
call toy cons which are like various
peripherals so this is actually pack or
and it's the VR pack this kit comes with
five toy guns I guess it's sort of
technically six because there's the
goggles that you think but the goggles
then plug into each different one yeah
the goggles slot into all the other toy
cons and that's how you play their
corresponding mini-games
yeah it's literally a switch that you
slide in front of these goggles which
then turn the switches screen into sort
of a stereoscopic 3d kind of thing I was
actually really impressed by that I
think before any time I see the lab oh I
always wonder how is this going to work
one thing that actually stuck out to me
too was that it did feel I kind of
hesitate to use the term one-to-one but
the lab oh did feel very accurate to
what I was doing right there wasn't any
really noticeable lag it wasn't like
totally uncalibrated from what we were
trying to do it worked yeah the head
tracking was very accurate so let's talk
about some of those experiences and the
first one we played was the blaster the
blaster is essentially an on-rails light
gun game so it takes you automatically
through this little city definitely
doesn't seem like there's very much
steps to it it's definitely one of those
typical lab Oh mini games where you play
it for a couple of minutes and you think
it's neat but and they'll really come
back to it but I enjoyed it for what it
was I feel like that's gonna be the
prevailing thought about a lot of these
but unfortunately there's more than just
the minigames that are included yes
because in addition to the blaster
there's the elephant toy con I'm not
really sure why they chose to style it
after an elephant because you're not an
elephant in that one yeah I don't
understand what that one matically at
all that what I think was probably my
least favorite of them just because it
was essentially a 3d art tool and
maneuvering the trunk of the elephant
around and you're using that just kind
of like draw objects in a 3d space and
there were a lot of tools you could
change colors you could add effects to
it and stuff you could rotate the object
in 3d but I feel like if you're not very
artistically inclined like I am there's
no real incentive to play that one sure
and that was kind of like the the first
minigame you can do with that then there
was sort of those like rube
goldberg style puzzle machines that you
can also play with that toy con each toy
con has like a secondary minigame we
didn't really get to try those though
yeah only tried one of each from what
they it's just though it seems like the
secondary minigames are where you're
going to have more fun like the first
one seems to introduce you to the
mechanics of how this toy con works the
second one really explores like having
more fun with it for lack of a better
term the Rube Goldberg style puzzles
were much more complex and you could
actually build your own and that's way
more in-depth than just you know a
drawing kit yeah the next one we played
probably had the least amount of depth I
would say which was the Frog the least
amount depth as far as gameplay but it
does have a really cool kind of extra 40
experience yeah I think like sensory
wise that one was probably the most
memorable of the bunch because that one
was controlled with the what a toy con
they called the wind pedal it was a
pedal that you'd lay down on the floor
and when you'd press it with your foot
it would just kind of like cause this
fan to flap up and blow air into your
face so you're pressing down the wind
pedal to make this frog in the game leap
upward and as you do that you'd feel the
wind in your face so it was very trippy
to feel the wind as you're seeing the
Frog jump the final one we played of the
toy cons was the camera yes that one was
probably my favorite
I'd have to say your object just to look
around and snap pictures of various
animals you you literally twist like
what would be a focus ring of a real
camera you snap the shoulder button of
the toy con that's inserted on the side
to take your picture and that felt
really cool that one was like the only
minigame that we got to play that
actually tried to approach a more
realistic visual style yeah so it was
very neat to look around the water and
see all the different animals swimming
around and in general it all just kind
of reminded me of Pokemon snap made me
want that even more this is literally
the perfect device for playing a new
Pokemon staff game it is perfectly
suited for it please Nintendo make that
happen
it would be a shame if that doesn't
happen now after we were done with this
toy cons we got to play in what they
call the VR Plaza we
is paired with the LeBeau garage or the
toy car garage rather but it seems to be
much more in-depth than the initial
garage you can literally make VR games
of your own you're not just programming
the joy con and toy con functions you're
actually programming these stages and
what the characters are doing on the
screen there are 64 minigames included
in the plaza made by the lab o
developers any one of which you can
literally just open up and then under
the hood see the logic they programmed
and make your own version of that game
or tweak what they made or make
something completely original we didn't
actually get to tinker around with the
underlying mechanics behind the games
but we got to look at a few of them and
it seems very like surprisingly flexible
to me there's a lot of different kinds
of games you could make we got to try
out this one little platformer we played
like a Smash Brothers ripoff yeah very a
very light version of Smash Bros yeah
you it was just like the side-scrolling
brawler we'd have to try to knock each
other off the stage yeah all of this
stuff was made within the toy car garage
like none of this is outside programming
that the team did this is all stuff that
was made within the toy con Garage VR so
anything you see like yeah you can
replicate and that left me very
impressed the ability to easily I guess
in quotes but easily create VR games of
your own and use pairing toy cons with
that I found very impressive definitely
and I'm really excited to see how people
will pair that with the toy con kits
that already exist right like there's
the robot pack from the original one I'd
be very curious to see how people
combine that that's a good point I
didn't even think of that
I feel like that's where I land on this
the same way I did with with the first
couple kits that they released was what
they have given you in terms of mini
games you can play it's fun for a time
but it's not super substantial but the
tools that they gave you to create your
own games and to create your own toy
cons that's really where lab uh shines
and I think you can see that even more
with this VR one there definitely make
it easier to jump into this one too
because if you want the entire set it's
$80 which is what the previous level
kids have also cost but this time around
they're also offering a starter sets
where it includes the goggles and the
blaster $40 and then if you like that
and you'd like to purchase their
remaining toy cons they
elmo's as separate expansions all of
those drop on April 12th look for more
lab talk around GameSpot and we will see
you guys next time
[Music]
you